the house trying to get to the bottom of
bias at the Biden FBI in doj and whether
upset School parents were investigated
as domestic terrorists the brand new
subcommittee holding its first of many
hearings on political weaponization
within those federal agencies but
Democrats don't want to hear it the
White House trying to brush off the
entire thing as a political stunt that's
rich my time in Congress I have never
seen anything like this dozens and
dozens of whistleblowers FBI agents
coming to us talking about what's going
on the political nature at the justice
department I'm deeply concerned about
the use of the select subcommittee as a
place to settle scores showcase
conspiracy theories and Advance an
extreme agenda that risk undermining
Americans faith in our democracy
Democrats say this is a waste of time
perhaps they should listen to this
former FBI agent
the FBI became politically weaponized
starting from the top in Washington and
trickling down to the field offices they
are not at the Liberty to allow their
personal political views or preferences
to determine their course of action or
inaction in any investigation Lady
Justice must remain blind
those that do not uphold these
responsibilities cause a negative ripple
effect throughout the agency in the
field it's as if there became two fbis
Americans see this and it is destroying
the bureau's credibility causing
Americans to lose faith in the agency
I didn't know Lady Justice was blind no
she's not she's not she's blindfolded uh
that's what I thought you did not think
that I did I thought interesting that's
enough from you judge
Dana it's like remember who blamed the
video I loved it who played the video
who pushed the video yeah who decided
that parents would be redefined as
domestic terrorists that's a question
that we should be asking so that's
actually you say that so the the
interesting thing about that is that
this group um
parents defending education right
they're the ones who figured it out they
uncovered these emails and do you
remember did you watch the wire yes of
course ringer Bell he he says are you
taking notes on a criminal conspiracy
and shaming them it turns out what these
guys were able to do just by using uh
foia which Jesse knows very well for you
for Freedom of Information Freedom of
Information requests they got emails
that say okay you are we're all
concerned about parents at these
teachers union or teachers PTA meetings
so you send us a letter and you suggest
that we should use a Patriot Act and if
you then if you send us that letter then
we can move on and do something else so
they were coordinating with this outside
group to work against the parents and
this committee is just beginning to
start to look at all these things the
parents is only the first thing and
they're going to go after now are they
going after radical Catholics yes those
are people that use their rosaries as a
weapon but no it's crazy like that this
is nuts judge this is nuts it really
it's not the a weaponization that's such
an overused word it's the
politicalization
there's a political ization but if
you're on the other end of an indictment
it is the weaponization and you know for
years we've heard about the Russia
collusion and and we've got all of these
hearings by Grassley and and by uh Ron
Johnson and and letters from
whistleblowers the bottom line is this
we've heard about it for six years it's
time that we have these hearings it's
time that we listen to the people who
are making the allegations in front of
the American people and they lied about
Russia collusion they lied to the fisa
court they lied about the Steele dossier
the nation was ruptured and now we've
got the FBI and the Department of
Justice sicking the the terrorist part
of their agencies after parents within
five days three really because it was a
weekend of hearing from the United
Federation of teachers so I mean this is
really
um an effort to put the evidence in
front of the American public because
elect is saying oh the Republicans you
know they're just having a hissy fit no
these are facts this is evidence and
we're tired of a two-tiered system of
justice and this will explain it Jessica
it is pretty funny I mean listening to
the Democrats call this a political
stunt when that's all you guys do with
your multiple your multiple hearings
your impeachments you guys invented the
political stunt you must be embarrassed
almost humiliated by that tape we played
I feel pretty okay about it
the Congressional political stunt has
obviously gone on for a while and I
would argue even had it was Kevin
McCarthy himself now Speaker of the
House who was on tape telling Hannity
that Benghazi the hearings were a
stunned to lower Hillary Clinton's
approval ratings and guess what they
managed to do that she testified for 11
hours didn't plead the fifth once
um what difference does that make though
well nice well in your face Jessica not
really you know what it is though it
doesn't matter does pleading The Fez
matter I I think no no what I'm saying
is if that's a political stunt we on the
five were we were damn interested in
that hearing because we wanted to know
about this video four people died
I'm just saying that someone who is now
the most powerful Republican admitted
that it was a political stunt so don't
say that we invented it so the hearings
were about a lot more than just teacher
parents becoming being called domestic
terrorists and I would add there were
parents who were threatening school
board members and teachers there was
also talk of I mean Chuck Grassley
um was talking about Hillary Clinton's
talking about Hillary Clinton's emails
were back in 2016 again
um that was already investigated it was
and 11 days before the election we all
know what Jim Comey did I mean Dan
Goldman who was my congressman and head
of the bagel caucus which I love asked
Jim Jordan when he was going to supply
the transcripts for the whistleblowers
that he kept mentioning to the minority
I think that if you were running a
committee and you want to be taken
seriously you should make sure that the
minority has the evidence that you keep
referring right like what they did in
the basement with Adam Schiff in that
whole collection one when the
Republicans were invited down to the
skiff and then ordered Chick-fil-A is
that what you're talking about I'm
talking about
just don't if you if you were running
the committee you would provide the
minority with all of the evidence I know
that you would judge look we're talking
about whistleblowers and without getting
into the laws that protect them unless
and until they have the ability to speak
publicly that's why they haven't already
let's but let them speak and at that
point you can tape record it or they'll
send you the transcript go to Jesse oh
which means she agrees with me now
you're running the B Block judge all
right so Grassley comes out today and he
says he's got an FBI whistleblower
that's telling him that the FBI knows
all about Hunter Biden's crimes and he
has evidence that Joe Biden knows about
all of Hunter's business and also has
evidence that Joe was involved in Hunter
Biden's criminal business and no one's
even talking about it you want to know
why because everybody already knows that
everybody already knows all of this
stuff yeah so what is the end game here
and this is my grievance ah you're gonna
have a hearing we get screwed rude then
we have a hearing nothing happens we get
screwed again we have a hearing nothing
happens same thing with Benghazi they
just got these guys to sign ndas and it
just goes away Hillary Clinton's
Department we don't have the Justice you
refer to the justice department we're
investigating the justice department and
then they laugh at us okay then DeSantis
gets elected Trump gets elected what's
he going to go in there and fire Chris
Ray last time anybody did that he got
impeached for it he got a special
counsel down his throat or you're going
and you leave Chris Ray in there and
then he blackmails you so we have an FBI
dictatorship here you either fire him
and die or if you can't or you can't
touch him and you still die and then the
media comes out doesn't even cover any
of the substances of the hearing thank
you so this thing is totally contained
over here and no one discusses it I'm
sick of these hearings make me feel
better guys tell me this is going
somewhere can I throw some in prison
yeah someone go to jail can someone get
fined had an objective Department of
Justice
they're under investigation department
just very quickly you guys got the
Durham investigation which was supposed
to blow the lid off and ended up with
nothing exactly
not jury was in DC you guys admitted you
planted the dossier you admitted you
framed him as a Trader and then you want
to investigate or investigation we're
investigating the investigators we're
investigating the investigators we don't
live in the same world it's just crazy
exactly your world's fake my world is
winning we're following the facts oh
you're winning because you guys are
corrupt we are winning you robbed my
vote this is the best you voted in New
York what are you talking about
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now